هذه زياره لاعبر عن احترامي لكل من
يحترمون الحريه
ولا يحتملون الطغيان كما يحدث لنا في
اوكرانيا شكرا جزيلا لكم اعضاء البرلمان
اعضاء
الساده السفراء والصحفيين ومندوبيل
وممثلين
والمجتمع الدولي ايها الشعوب الكريمه
شعوب
هولندا
وانا سعيد بان اكون في بلدكم القوي ارض
الحريه والعداله التي
هي خيم عالميه
ونحترمها وهي ذات صله بالامور التي ساتحدث
عنها اليوم كلنا نرغب بان نرى تغييرا
يحدث هنا
او او مختلف هنا في
اللهايك شخص
لابد من ان يحكم عليه
للجرائم التي ارتكبها بحق
واخترق فيها القانون الدولي وامن ان نرى
هذا
وسننتصر في نهايه الامر ليس انتصارا في
ساحه المعركه وليس ضد هذه الاعتداءات
والعدوان بل كلنا نرى من يجتمعون هنا
ليشاهد الاوكرانيين يدافعون عن انفسهم
وهناك رغبه كبيره في المساعده
هذا الشعور والايمان بان دولتنا معرضه
للخطر وانها تستطيع ان تنتصر على
معتدل واحد
وبالتالي يمكننا
ننهي العدوان كفكره
نشات في فكر الشخص يرى بنفسه انه يتمتع
بحصانه حصانه
دفعته لان يقوم بهذا العدوان
حربا عدائيه في التاريخ فيها
امر مشترك
المعتدي دائما
لم يكن
يصدق انه كان
يجب ان يحسب ما سياتي في نهايه الامر وانه
في نهايه هذه الحرب سيقف امام وجه العداله
وسيحاسب هؤلاء يحاولون ان يعتدوا بطغيان
دون ان يكترثوا بسبب ما يشعرون به بحصانه
هكذا
يقومون بعملهم وانا ممتن لكم جميعا
ولهولندا لكل ما قدمتموه من سلاح
ومواد تموينيه قدمتموها لاوكرانيا
لتعزيز دفاعاتنا
لنكون جاهزين
الا اننا كلنا نعلم ان السلام الدائم
لن يحقق بالسلاح بل بقوه السلام
والحريه
وسياده القانون
علينا ان نعمل معا لضمان هذه العداله
وليس بتقديم وعود فارغه بل العمل من اجل
الحريه
وليس بتقديم حصانه بل
من خلال تحقيق العداله
وليس بقبول العنف الا اننا لابد ان نحترم
القيم والحريه والعداله
وانها كلها تحترم وتحل محل الحرب هذا ما
نحتاج اليه الان
سته الاف
ومئه وتسعه وثلاثين هذا الرقم الذي افكر
به هذا هو عدد الجرائم جرائم الحرب الذي
قام بها الروس في هذه الحاره
هذه الجرائم الروسيه
ادت الى مقتل 100
2007 اوكرانيا من بينهم 11 طفلا
اكثر من 400 جريح خلال شهر واحد
وهذا استمر على مدى اشهر ويوم امس
هذا حدث في خرسان
روسيا قتلت 23 شخص
وتسعه واربعين جريح
[موسيقى]
ونتذكر ايضا احتلال ارضنا في القرم
التي قاموا بها بحرب كبيره في الدمباس
الالاف قتلوا والضحايا
يتجاوزون الالاف الصواريخ الروسيه قتلت
مدنيين
والملايين من الضربه الصاروخيه في
الدومباس
كل شخص قتله
المحتل
بسبب هذا العدوان الروسي على ارضنا
وكل معتقل تم تعذيبه وهو لدى في السجون
الروسيه وكل مدينه
دمرتها القوات الروسيه وكل معاناه دعوني
وبعد
باستخدام
واستخدام وباياد روسيه
هذه الايادي الروسيه هي المسؤوله هذا امر
بشع
ودقيقه صمت
احدده على كل من فقدناهم في هذه الحرب
مشاهدينا متابعين نتابع معكم اذا دقيقه
استمتعت اليها الرئيس الاوكراني خلال
كلمته في زيارته للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
وننتظر ان اكمال هذه الكلمه بعد انتهاء
دقيقه الصمت هذه قالت لي قبل قليل
اوكرانيا الخطر ونريد اجراءات حقيقيه
لملاحقه القياده الروسيه وبوتين يستحق
المحاكمه بسبب جرائمه في اوكرانيا اضاف
ايضا الرئيس الاوكراني
انه متاكد ان محاكمه بوتين ستحدث عندما
تنتصر اوكرانيا وقال علينا العامه لتحقيق
العداله ومحاكمه بوتين من اجل قيم الحريه
وجرائم روسيا في اوكرانيا تسببت في مقتل
احد عشر طفلا شهريا اذا نعود لمتابعه كلمه
الرئيس الاوكراني
جريمه روسيه واحده ادت الى كل هذه الجرائم
المتتاليه هذا هو العدوان الذي بدا
جريمه اساسيه وهم المسؤولين عن السلام ولا
يمكن
يفرض السلام الا عبر المحكمه الدوليه
واوروبا كان عليها ان تواجه مثل هذه
الامور نتيجه لذلك نرى الحروب في سياق
هذه الاحكام التي تصدر عن المحكمه الدوليه
ان الحرب العدائيه ليست بجريمه دوليه
بل هي انتهاك
وهي جريمه حرب تشمل
يعني ان هذا الشر سيقع على الكل رغم انه
وقع في اوكرانيا
ونرى هذا الدور الدور الاوروبي ولهذا
السبب
نصره على
اقامه محكمه دوليه لجرائم الحرب الروسيه
واحقاق العداله عبر معاقبه المسؤولين عن
جرائم الحرب
والا يكون هناك تكرارا لمثل هذه الاعمال
العدائيه عبر العداله هو الحل لا يجب ان
نسعى لمبررات
ولا نريد ان تتكرر نقاط
الضعف الموجوده في القانون الدولي حاليا
بل لابد من تصويبه بحيث ان تكون هذه
الانماط
السائده لابد ان تغطيها القوانين الدوليه
بحيث تتجاوز كل هذه الانتهاكات وبالتالي
سيكون من الضعف لكم ولنا
ولجميع الدول
ان نترك العداله للتاريخ هذا سيكون فيه
ظلم لابنائنا لاحفادنا وان نورثهم مشكله
كان بامكاننا ان نحلها قبل ان ننقلها لهم
هذا من خلال المحكمه الدوليه استدامه
السلام
يحتاج العداله الكامه
التامه بحق المعتدي
العلم يجب ان لا يكون لديه اي خشيه من
اعطاء صلاحيه الكامله للعداله فنحن لا
نخشى شيء المعتدي يجب ان يشعر بقوه طغيان
العداله
وهذه هي مسؤوليتنا التاريخيه لاكثر من جيل
لايقاع
العقوبه الكامله على المعتدي وان يحاسب
على اعتدائه لبلدنا
وهناك ايضا معتدين اخرين في هذه الحرب ولا
بد ان يحاسب من اجل تحقيق السلام وتحقيق
السلم والامن
وبالتالي لابد من
تحميل المسؤوليه
للمحتل الروسي واود ان اشكر الفريق العامل
في هذه المحكمه
وكل من يخدمون الحريه
وهناك جهه واحده قادره على الرد على
الجريمه الاساسيه وهي جريمه
العدوان وهي المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه هي
ليست بامر هجين
بل
ليست بتسويه
تمكن السياسيين من ان يقولوا
ان القضيه انتهت ويدعون ذلك
الا ان المحكمه الدوليه الجنائيه هي
الوحيده القادره على
تحقيق العداله وانا اشكر
قياده
هولندا رئيس الوزراء الحكومه
البرلمان على دورهم ادور المهم بالنسبه
لنا
ونشكركم على هذه المحكمه الجنائيه واشكر
جميع الاطراف المسؤولين عن هذه
العمليات وهنا في لاهاي
ستقام هذه المحكمه وهي خطبه للامام
لايجاد اليه تعويض
من حيث نحصل عليها من المعتدي ليتم تعويض
المتضرر
وهذا عقوبه ايضا على على شن الحرب اشكركم
ان
العداله لكم ولنا امر مهم اشكركم اشكر
الهولندا
التي جعلت العداله امر ناجح
وفي الرابع من مايو
وفي المساء ستسمعون وستكونون معنا
لاحياء ذكرى كل من فقدناهم
الحرب العالميه الثانيه
نتذكرها ونتذكر الاوكرانيين من رجال ونساء
واطفال
كان من الممكن ان يكونوا احياء بيننا الان
لكن للاسف هذا
العدوان والحرب لم ترغب في ابقائهم
ونحن سنعمل على انهاء هذه الحرب شكرا
كنا معكم مشاهدينا في متابعه لكلمه
الجنائيه الدوليه وقال من خلالها روسيا
ارتكبت اكثر من سته الاف جريمه حرب الشهر
الماضي اضافه
ان جرائم روسيا في اوكرانيا تسببت في مقتل
احد عشر طفلا شهريا وعلينا العمل لتحقيق
العداله ومحاكمه بوتين من اجل قيم الحريه
ومتاكد من ان محكمه بوتين بل محاكمه
بوتنسا تحدث عندما تنتصر اوكرانيا قال
ايضا يستحق المحاكمه بسبب جرائمه في
اوكرانيا واوكرانيا معرضه للخطر ونريد
اجراءات حقيقيه لملاحقه القياده الروسيه
حول هذا الملف
المزيد والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات